muy buenas noches primero quiero
agradecerles a todos ustedes su
presencia gracias yo soy juan salvador
guerrero productor audiovisual y
actualmente coordino la carrera de
comunicación audiovisual y publicidad
digital en una universidad en la ciudad
de méxico que se llama amer y que con
cada kilo un proyecto en el que comparto
créditos con grandes personas y que de
alguna manera tenemos contacto directo
con los estudiantes con jóvenes que
tienen este ímpetu de estudiar estas
carreras pero yo les vengo a platicar de
algo que me fascina que es el acto de
escribir un guión cinematográfico una
obra de teatro ese espacio donde estás
sentado frente a una pantalla en blanco
una hoja en blanco y que de repente en
tu cabeza giran historias persona
es hasta olores y no sabes cómo ordenar
todos esos pensamientos y creo que este
enfrentas a un acto de verdad de coraje
primero para ordenar todos esos esos
preceptos y una vez que ya los ordenas
viene una fase que debo confesar cuando
tú eres artista o cuando escribes no
aceptas tan fácilmente que es entra el
ego porque tú quieres que esa pieza ese
guión sea de donde descubras la el hilo
negro que sea una pieza de arte y que
cuando lo lea tu cliente o cuando lo
lean tus actores te digan guau
felicidades eres lo máximo y pero
realmente lo importante para mí es la
voluntad de cometer lo que yo considero
un acto de comunicación porque porque un
guión significa que voy a poder dar un
mensaje o simplemente también como
manera de catártica voy a entender un
sentimiento universal le voy a dar forma
a algo que está en mi mente y que en el
momento en el que yo lo escriba lo voy a
entender o simplemente voy a aprovechar
ese pretexto para poder generar mensajes
a través de imágenes en movimiento
una vez que el caos y el ego se
apacientan me dedico a escribir y
entonces voy a la siguiente fase donde
hoy hay y acudo perdón a mi sentido
común y como traduzco yo el sentido
común como estos valores y creencias que
todos tenemos en el deber ser pero no lo
hago para perpetuar esas esas creencias
y esos hábitos lo hago porque me gusta
escribir historias donde los personajes
precisamente rompan con todo eso porque
yo creo que tenemos la oportunidad en
este en este acto de creación de poder
dar mensajes insisto y es aquí cuando
recuerdo mis clases de lenguaje
audiovisual y al mil el mismo
aristóteles cuando no sé de manera
académica
cuáles son los elementos que tengo que
considerar bueno es el espacio el tiempo
y al final los personajes yo lo
particular primero me concentro en los
primeros dos espacio y tiempo porque
todos los que estamos aquí sentados no
no seríamos lo que lo que somos en este
tiempo y en este espacio
entonces me concentro en observar por
qué porque en el 2019 2020 2021 las
formas de comunicación las formas de ser
van cambiando las ideas también van
cambiando
entonces es importante siempre observar
además de que yo creo que el cine o
cualquier audiovisual nos brinda la
oportunidad de conocer experiencias unas
veces desagradables y no hace falta que
las vivamos nosotros para poder entender
y hacer cambios en nuestra vida y les
voy aquí les quiero compartir una
experiencia que a mí me transformó hace
cuatro años yo estaba trabajando en un
cortometraje y una amiga estaba haciendo
labor social en el centro de
readaptación femenil en la ciudad de
mexico santa martha acatitla ella se
encargaba de hacer colectas para los
niños que habitaban en el reclusorio y
en una de esas surgió el proyecto de
sacar una colección de cortometrajes
entonces me invita yo acepto yo no sabía
a qué me iba a enfrentar cuando yo
asistí a ese lugar evidentemente cuando
yo acepté también le pedí conocer la
penitenciaria que está al lado en ese
lugar en santa marta tenemos el centro
de readaptación femenil y enseguida está
a la pena que es un centro donde los
reclusos varones son los que tienen las
máximas penas es decir penas arriba de
100 años
entonces yo pedí que el mismo día porque
siempre me ha gustado tomar al toro por
los cuernos pues visitar ambos lugares
yo no sabía que me y con que me iba a
topar lo único que sabía es que tenía
miedo y me arriesgue y fui y la verdad
es que lo que yo presencié en ese lugar
me transformó en qué sentido
yo conocí a personas inocentes conocí a
personas culpables conocí a delincuentes
que decían sí mate y robe y solamente
estoy esperando a salir para volver a
hacerlo pero también conocí a mujeres
violentadas por mucho tiempo y en el
momento en el que ellas decidieron poner
un alto las culpables fueron ellas
y eso me transformó porque entonces
comencé a pensar en una palabra la
palabra libertad era el común
denominador todos hablaban de eso
libertad libertad para hacer y a mí ese
elemento en particular conecto con lo
que yo hacía porque al final cuando tú
estás escribiendo un guión partes del
supuesto de que todos los seres humanos
nos movemos a través de nuestras
decisiones nosotros decidimos hacia
donde yo decidí calificar para dar una
charla y compartir el espacio con
ustedes y cada uno de ustedes también a
su vez decidió estar aquí por muchas
razones
y sobre todo en ese contexto del cual
les estoy hablando te das cuenta que
también muchas personas estuvieron en
ese en esa condición de hacinamiento de
encierro por sus propias decisiones yo
no creo en las buenas o malas decisiones
creo en las decisiones correctas para
nosotros
y de verdad es que fue un choque
interesante ya después cuando a lo largo
de 34 años aproximadamente fui
continuamente cada fin de semana a
reconocer ese espacio platicábamos
porque fue un proyecto de mucho tiempo
con todo el equipo nos quedaba claro una
cosa nosotros no queríamos hablar del
sistema penitenciario no queríamos
hablar de las condiciones que vivían los
presos nosotros queríamos hablar de esos
sentimientos universales que en un lugar
pequeño y reducido se magnificaban el
amor la esperanza el odio y la fe yo
recuerdo perfectamente que platicaba en
algún momento con el director del centro
de escolar y él me decía yo soy ateo
pero gracias a dios aquí mucha gente no
se mata entre sí
y gracias adiós a la santa muerte a
quien quieras pero las creencias han
logrado bajar el índice de asesinatos
entre ellos
entonces nos quedaba muy claro que
nosotros no queríamos hablar de cosas
desagradables queríamos hablar de las
madres que sufren porque a determinada
edad sus hijos si los padres porque
había casos tan espectaculares en el mal
sentido donde los papás ambos estaban
encerrados uno en el femenil y enfrente
estaba el papá en la peni literal había
unas escaleras donde ella le gritaba y
el hijo vivía con la mamá pero a los 8
años
si no tienes familia que cuiden a tus
hijos inmediatamente se van al dif
entonces nosotros lo que buscábamos era
mostrar esos sentimientos porque nos
parecían importantes y de ahí surgió el
título del proyecto lo llamamos ocultos
y el eslogan nos parecía muy interesante
para estar prepara esta encerrado no
hace falta estar preso porque también
entendimos que todos como seres humanos
a veces nos vamos metiendo en nuestra
cotidianidad y vamos perdiendo de vista
cosas tan importantes como hablar a los
ojos como reconocernos como hablar con
nuestros con nuestras familias con la
familia
expresarte simplemente eso es lo que
queríamos nosotros mostrar en ese
proyecto y a nosotros nos sirvió como
ejercicio porque cuando tú escribes un
guión lo que tienes que hacer o cuando
de repente yo he dirigido también lo que
es un ejercicio que hago con mis actores
es crear una biografía de ese personaje
que van a interpretar saber de dónde
viene que a donde donde creció no es lo
mismo ser
es estar en méxico que en eeuu en fin es
determinar todas esas diferencias para
saber hacia dónde va ese personaje y
reconocer por qué tomamos ciertas
decisiones eso es lo importante y un
poco compartir con ustedes que con el
ejercicio y con el reconocimiento que yo
hice en ese lugar entendí también las
decisiones que yo estaba tomando el
valor de decidir y de entender que toda
decisión tiene una consecuencia por eso
insisto yo no creo en malas ni buenas
decisiones simplemente en decisiones
correctas para nosotros siempre y cuando
también no pasemos por encima de otros
y pues ese proyecto al final quedó
enlatado quedó en papel por si por
muchas razones evidentes también hubo
cambio de la administración en el
sistema penitenciario y quedó ahí la
labor que hicimos dentro y el
reconocimiento fue muy importante y pues
al final y como les comentaba esta
cuestión de entender hacia dónde íbamos
y cómo corre la vida me lleva a otro
espacio a otro momento en el que me
entendí otras cosas yo hace el año
pasado estaba trabajando en dos
proyectos muy importantes para mí el
primero es que en la universidad donde
trabajo me dieron el sí para crear un
club de teatro yo siempre he pensado que
el arte nos conecta y sobre todo en una
en un ámbito universitario en un ámbito
escolar académico el teatro no solamente
te da tablas para expresarte te da
tablas también para entender el mundo en
general
entonces estaba yo en la con la creación
del club de teatro y por otro lado
estaba asistiendo la dirección de un
espectáculo monumental en el auditorio
nacional era el estreno del réquiem de
mozart
era un espectáculo dramatizado no
solamente era un concierto entonces
imagínense toda la adrenalina
independientemente de eso no he dejado
también mi labor como productor
audiovisual entonces yo estaba
trabajando estaba en mi rutina así
trabajando como robot y de repente un
día un fin de semana
se meten a mi departamento y me roban
todo mi equipo
yo me quedé
en shock primero porque imagínense
entrar a tu departamento encontrarlo
violentado y de repente yo no sabía qué
hacer además en mi mundo en ese momento
yo no encontraba otra solución no tenía
nada no tenía herramientas de trabajo
y no no encontraba sin embargo yo
continué con estos dos proyectos
me demandaban mucho tiempo por un lado
estaba trabajando con jóvenes
entusiastas creando un montaje y por el
otro estaba trabajando en una en un
espectáculo donde donde estaba
coordinando trabajos con la sinfónica
nacional con la compañía de danza de
cuba y con un coro de 40 personas
yo seguir trabajando seguir trabajando
realmente quiero comentarles que cuando
yo llegaba a casa en el lugar donde
donde sufrí el asalto
yo me deprimía estaba solo
y fue un día que entendí con una
experiencia que me pareció maravillosa
que también tiene que ver con la
creación esta creación de la que le
estoy hablando dos semanas antes porque
igual que mis visitas en el reclusorio
yo estrenaba una semana el montaje
teatral universitario y a la siguiente
el 7 de noviembre se estrenaba en el
auditorio el réquiem de mozart me
acuerdo que yo llego a la universidad
que estaba muy apurado y de repente me
recibe mi asistente y me dice juansa vas
a tener que monte correr la obra tú
yo le dije pensé que era una broma
entonces yo seguí caminando de repente
veo no sé si ustedes conozcan estábamos
montando la obra de la dama de negro es
una obra donde solamente hay dos actores
en escena y de repente me encuentro a mi
compañero un colega profesor y me dice
cuando lo vas a tener que hacer tú
entonces yo traía toda esta energía de
los ensayos con en el centro histórico
en fin y aparte de la depresión del
asalto y yo dije bueno pues qué más
falta tiene un perro pues ya yo lo que
hice fue quitarme mi chamarra y decir a
ver
adriana que me ponga en el micrófono
sale faltaban tres horas para estrenar
yo era el director pero no me sabía las
líneas y entonces los que conocen la
obra sabrán que se prestaba a traer
libreto en mano entonces le dije a mi
colega vente para acá y vamos a correr
la obra con libreto en mano porque la
obra de la dama en negro habla
precisamente de una persona que está
buscando un director escénico para dar
el mensaje que hay un ente que cobra las
almas de los niños entonces dije nos
vamos a correrlo y estuve esas tres
horas corriendo el ensayo corriendo el
ensayo porque porque yo me di cuenta que
me rodeaba gente que con pasión estaba
trabajando en algo que había decidido
dar su tiempo para que estrenamos una
obra escolar
ese momento para mí fue mágico porque de
repente ya vamos y entonces quiero
decirles que cuando dieron la tercera
llamada fue como un acto catárquico dije
va sed y sed y a la depresión que yo
estaba sintiendo a la adrenalina de
estrenar una obra de teatro con libreto
en mano y con ese temor de hijo de no me
voy a equivocar
porque de repente era estar con el
libreto y dar la línea y estar leyendo y
hacer marometas para disimular el que yo
no me sabía el el diálogo
fue maravilloso porque cuando yo cuando
termina la obra de repente ya nos
bajamos porque era una festividad de
muertos me encuentro con un niño que
emocionado me estaba narrando las
escenas que le habían encantado así con
esa emoción y quería matricularse en el
club de teatro y ahí fue cuando yo
entendí que me creí a la perfección el
papel de víctima
dije guau agarre y después de ver al
niño me fui al baño y me puse a llorar
como loco porque en ese momento me di
cuenta que era capaz de hacer eso y más
y qué bueno que me sucedió porque días
después tenía que coordinar con mi
director a más de 100 personas en el
auditorio nacional
entonces cuando yo y cuando termina esa
obra y entiendo que me había creído
perfectamente el papel de víctima y que
yo era capaz disfruté muchísimo la
experiencia siguiente que fue el réquiem
de mozart
porque aparte pues bueno está estaba
ante una una pieza musical que tenía
mucho significado porque es una de las
piezas de mozart inacabadas la casi casi
la literal la escribió en su lecho de
muerte la terminó un estudiante porque
estaban vivían endeudados y entonces la
esposa le dijo a un estudiante de mozart
terminal a porque ya está pagada en fin
y sobre todo la visión que se tenía en
ese espectáculo también era un
espectáculo que a través de una misa de
muertos pretendía dar el mensaje de lo
que estamos haciendo los seres humanos
en nuestra contra la violencia la muerte
la incomunicación etcétera pero ese fue
un espectáculo multimedia que tenía
danza que evidentemente teníamos al coro
y en fin ese momento a lo que yo voy es
que entendí en ese hace dos años hace
poco el poder que tiene la decisi las
decisiones que tomamos que nosotros
empezamos y estamos todos parados frente
a una hoja en blanco nosotros decidimos
que escribimos en nuestra historia por
eso es que yo los invito a que escriban
la historia de su vida la narrativa de
su vida tomando las decisiones correctas
porque en una de esas no sabemos pero
tal vez alguien más está interesado en
escuchar esa historia y no solamente en
escucharla sino en participar en en tu
historia
así es que les agradezco y los invitó
una vez más a que escriban la narrativa
de su vida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]